[Music]
tens of thousands of people in the east
of the democratic republic of congo have
fled their homes in fear of their lives
it was m23 rebels that were chasing us
the m23 rebel group has taken several
small towns
some of the residents have fled to
neighbouring uganda others towards the
regional capital gomer
churches and schools like this one are
overrun with people seeking shelter
we saw people being killed by stray
bullets and those who could save
themselves are here
the congolese army has launched a
counter-offensive and retaken some of
the territory
congo's government says neighbouring
rwanda is behind m23 supporting it with
weapons and soldiers rwanda denies it
we as the government don't believe that
the m23 rebels themselves have the
military equipment which they claim to
have on the ground according to the
reports from our soldiers this is why
our suspicion of foreign support is
confirmed
ten years ago m23 took control of
swathes of eastern congo un
investigators said it was backed by
rwanda congo's army eventually defeated
them with military support from the un
and other african countries
this time congo's army has struggled to
contain the attacks launched by m23 over
the last six months
both uganda and rwanda have been accused
of fueling congo's conflicts and looting
minerals ever since they invaded in the
1990s a recent attempt to get the three
presidents together for talks in kenya's
capital nairobi failed to produce
results
the violence and humanitarian crisis are
growing and the un says it's deeply
concerned
malcolm webb al jazeera